compare triangles here right now we
looked at these kinds of shapes are we
looking at similar figures and I'll ask
you to draw these triangles so they
weren't roughly similar to each other
they have the same features they have
same proportions but where they differ
is of course science so yours pair of
triangles now you see that side that
I've mounted the question mark okay when
we look at similar figures you worked
out how to be able to calculate a side
like that what do we use what kind of
knowledge or reasoning did we employ to
be able to say that this side is can
someone tell you it is I have no right
angles in this triangle by the way it is
a right angle triangle but you don't
know that yes it doesn't matter what is
the actual length
what about what it's gonna be ten right
it's gonna be ten
now hold on a second how did you know
think back like two three lessons how
did you know was going to be ten yeah
okay fantastic in similar figures the
ratios of now ratios of watching ratios
of is a special word not just any
science ratios of corresponding sides
thank you very much so you see this one
it is fine then married together I get
matched and what are the tens right to
one of the five they match in the same
way this two is what corresponds to the
tenth okay you can see the ratio it's
one to find and so if you take that one
to five ratio and apply it here you get
two to ten okay so we said corresponding
sides and similar figures are in the
same ratio great okay now what I want
you to do redraw the same pair of shapes
but don't don't cleaning labels on it
okay so if I had the same small triangle
and the same big triangle okay what we
have learned in trigonometry so far and
if you learn from previously is what we
reviewed yesterday is that for instance
if you have a side and rather knowing
more science if you know and angle
that's what we started with yesterday to
make all of our triangles if you don't
able and if you're in a right angle
triangle okay in the same way that
having all the sides here tells you a
lot about this shape down here you've
got a side but you've got these angles
and we saw no matter what size of
triangle you made if you have the same
angles over here down in the corners
right you were always going to get the
same ratio right now have a look I mean
I traces because it was basically the
one digit yesterday you have your 30
degrees here what pair of sides of my
looking at I've got opposite opposite
and hypotenuse right so that's why in
this case you'd say sign and where you
can write it down
sine of 30 degrees is equal to five
opposite over there question mark
hypotenuse right except Sunday degrees
like all triangles in this proportion
are gonna have the same number there we
never we did the table and we all
punched it out at they would be
exceptions like some measurements that
were slightly off but all God uh-huh as
that ratio right that ratio of five over
whatever right it's gonna be tough and
you can see I can cross multiply key and
say your unknown is 2 times 5 which is
tens the same shape as before okay now
this is the working we're doing now
versus you know I guess here I would
write how to look here I would say one
two five one two five that ratios
corresponding sides that's going to be 2
2 we didn't know what was before
like that it was ten okay so you know
what you're looking at with these little
figures is tell me about these guys
relate to each other that guy and that
guy but down here I haven't even talked
about a second triangle yet have i right
I've just been in this triangle as well
okay so I'm looking at these these sides
other and comparing them but it's the
same you see it's the same ratio idea
question - yeah that's exactly right
divided by 1/2 is the same as
multiplying 2 and what this is saying is
remember you made 24 24 me that all hand
at 30 degrees in there okay when you see
this end is what it's implying for you
is that there is some out somewhere out
there some triangle that has this exact
ratio right this 30 degrees this right
ankle right this one and this 2 which
you can measure out using your ruler and
so on and this actually ends up being
the square root of 3 which is about one
point seven that's where the number of
cultural okay so trigonometry is built
on the foundation of Silla trains that's
why I had a peas in mm3 about similarity
okay so we're focusing on is this is
school I just demonstrated for you here
finding sides and triangles if you know
some angles you know you're know writing
a triangle if you just have one side you
could find out all the rest of them
using this sign cause tab this kind of
hidden idea underneath right you know it
now you know this mystery and so you can
unlock any triangle you what so there
was one example which I walked you
through I want you to see if you can
help me out with this one it's not gonna
be as the
you think it's something like this and
let's put it over
okay so before we got to these nice
numbers 30 degrees and 19 degrees 19
degrees 19 have a significant number
that was just a coincidence that it gave
us one two two and then one two three
this is some random a but I have no idea
what's going to do okay but I know
there's gonna be some similar triangle
out there with this same number angles
two different sides but I can use that
relationship somehow with my calculators
home okay so how are you look here if
you have another color they'll be really
helpful I want to think about this angle
where I'm standing I often actually just
like with the um you know the elevations
and drawing the things I like to
sometimes put a person there top it this
angle to help me remember where am i
situated when I look at the features of
this triangle you look at the two sides
that are there on a diagram that are
marked out for us right once though ones
I know what are they in relation to
where I'm standing
I've got to choose from opposite
adjacent and hypotenuse what do we got
okay I've got an opposite side over here
they're 15 right so this one I'm going
to make what does the opposite one it's
all the way over there now it's true
enough X meters is right next to where I
am but it's not the adjacent side why
not
it's actually the hypotenuse do you see
that the right angle tells me this has
to be that hypotenuse the longest side
in the whole triangle even though I
don't even know what the length of this
is this one's got to be longer so I'm
gonna leave with this one as hypotenuse
okay so how do you identify opposite and
hypotenuse is the pairing I got I know
with sohcahtoa which of the truth ratios
would be useful to me which ones let me
sign again right so I want to say sine
of this angle that I'm interested in
okay 26 degrees it's opposite opposite
on hypotenuse 50 over X okay so X is the
thing I'm trying to work it out this is
like back in m1 this is solving
equations it just needs rearranged a
little bit right looks to me like I can
do two things at once
I can get this X rather than being down
the bottom it's a bit of an awkward spot
to be I'm gonna multiply both sides by X
okay so that's gonna appear over here on
the left and it's gonna disappear and
over here on the right because I've
multiplied through does that make sense
we're following with me but not only
that I want the X to be by itself at the
moment there's a signed 26° over here on
the left so how do I get rid of it I
should divide through very good so signs
when he sees he's going to appear and
they're kind of like swap places if that
makes sense
now I've no idea what sine 26 degrees is
thankfully I have calculator that will
talk me
I doubt it
I doubt it so with you calculator there
15 you may know signed sign 26 and it's
going to give you a number
can I get one actually coming in all the
decimal places and then we'll
approximate together before we go yes
sorry I'm in the wrong word thirty-four
point seven five so let's just go to one
decimal place
okay so let's pause remember what we
just established okay we've got a
lengthy by the way since check doesn't
it
does it look like something reasonable
yeah I think so I know my scale is pre
terrible but I know this is gonna be the
longest time the triangle it's about
twice as long that makes sense it's very
similar to that triangle of in 30
degrees 26 they're not far off father
okay so what did we do in the triangle
that was my first step do you remember
it's colored remember what my first step
one I need to know what the sides were
in relation to my angle okay you might
like to write that down because it's a
helpful step step one what you want to
do is say well opposite hypotenuse
adjacent which one is which right so
identify the sides in relation to the
angle okay and that's the angle up that
so I drew my man over there
step two once I knew that they were
opposite the hypotenuse what did I do
with that knowledge thing I think it's
when I started writing the equation
very good I thought okay sine cos tan
which one is going to connect besides
I've got seeing as it's officer on that
potenuse what I want is to identify the
ratio sine cos or tan that connects the
sides
well that relates the sides together
okay
so then I said sine and then from there
I was just filling in the details that
were in the question right 26 degrees is
the angle 15 over X has to be in that
Euler because it's opposite hypotenuse
after all okay so step three is to write
and then solve the equation and you
could see we had to do some house where
we have to move things around so I got
the X exactly where I wanted and your
calculator took care of the rest